alors que québec promet un financement
de 475 millions de dollars dans le
développement de l'aluminium rio tinto
annonce de son côté un investissement de
près de 110 millions pour produire de
l'aluminium à faible teneur en carbone
on en parle ce soir avec sébastien roth
qui est le directeur exécutif des
opérations de rio tinto au québec qu'on
soit monsieur ross
bonsoir monsieur fusion ce que vous
annoncer aujourd'hui vous l'aviez quand
même déjà annoncées vous l'aviez annulé
en 2001 en 2019 et puis l'art et annonce
aujourd'hui de 16 cuves de technologie
ap60 au complexe de jean-pierre qu'est
ce qui vous permet aujourd'hui d'aller
de l'avant
mais en fait je dirais que le projet
jamais été financées il ya pas été
annoncé comme tel il ya trois ans mais
c'est clair que quand on fait un
investissement on regarde c'est le
marché porteur et si le marché porteur
sur une longue période donc on veut pas
faire des investissements selon
nécessairement les cycles économiques et
l'actuel mans on voit une croissance
dans le marché le marché porteur donc
c'était vraiment un bon timing pour
investir pour le futur est ce que vous
auriez pu aller plus loin les syndicats
voulaient un engagement encore plus
important jusqu'à 96 q pourquoi ne pas
aller plus loin
mais en fait et les infrastructures pour
les as cuves étaient déjà disponibles
cette fois qui avait été pensé en 2013
quand on a construit l'usiné ap60 à
l'origine donc on voulait faire un
projet sur lequel on pourra aller
rapidement et aussi qu'en terme de
l'ingénierie détaillée était complétée
donc le fait d'aller rapidement sinon ça
nous aurait pris plusieurs années pour
aller pour plus gros cependant ce qu'ont
annoncé aujourd'hui c'est qu'en plus de
la non ce débat est vif qui est un
projet qui est super super le fond du
super important pour l'organisation
c'est la prof en disant qu'une compagnie
au québec fera une annonce de
progression dans la production
d'aluminium primaire ces convois lance
en parallèle les études pour faire plus
de qu on n'a pas encore statué sur le
nombre de cuves additionnel qu'on peut
faire mais on va lancer les études on va
compléter les génériques pour voir si on
peut aller au delà des saints est ce qu
ce qui est important de montrer cela
fait soixante toujours
de technologie ap60 toujours l'autre
élément qui est important on l'esa
excuse un projet de transition pour vous
savez quand on travaille conjointement
avec notre partenaire a le poids et les
deux allées de gouvernement et apple sur
une technologie qui s'appelle lycées
lycées secteur et gilles à les mettre au
pot du tout de co2 donc c'est vraiment
une technologie de rupture ça demeure un
projet de recherche et développement les
échéanciers qu'on nous annonce il ya
déjà l'on rencontre est bien évidemment
mais vont au delà de 20 25 donc on
trouvait aussi que le ça excuse c'est le
meilleur projet c'est la plus faible
empreinte de co2 sur les technologies
traditionnelles de fabrication d'un
million donc c'est un beau projet de
transition en attendant la technologie
liste pour aller vers il ici ce qu'est
ce qui va se passer avec la vieille
alumineries de jonquière qui va fermer
en 2025 le syndicat exprime beaucoup
d'inquiétude vous les entendez 500 à 600
emplois qui sont en jeu qu'est ce que
vous dites aux travailleurs
ben d'oran on travaille de concert avec
avec les nos partenaires syndicaux dans
ce dossier là bien évidemment on est
très au fait qu'on a un permis pour
opérer jusqu'à la fin de 20 25 et que
plusieurs emplois en jeu donc le ca
excuse c'est la première réponse lui
bien évidemment c'est pour la dernière
réponse à notre organisation rio tinto a
annoncé un des envies des objectifs
ambitieux de décarbonisation et elie six
veaux contribuer à ce bien évidemment il
ya d'autres choses on veut rentrer dans
le marché du recyclage on a commencé à
investir dans le recyclage l'an dernier
on a d'ailleurs une fournaise de
recyclage de l'usiné de laterrière qui
va commencer la production l'an prochain
et on travaille sur des projets de
remplacement de nos cuves avec les
projets de recyclage aussi est au coeur
de notre stratégie que d'autres projets
oui je comprends que d'autres projets
mais ce que vous êtes capable de prendre
l'engagement aujourd'hui qui report que
dans les cinq à six cents travailleurs
personne va perdre son emploi à la fin
non en fait ça dépend quand je regarde
le bilan d'emploi régionales c'est ce
qu'ils sont vos verres des nouvelles
technologies qu'on remplace une
technologie de 1954 il va à vau -
d'entourer le bilan régional cependant
on veut assurer une transition
harmonieuse la main d'oeuvre on
travaille avec les syndicats l'attrition
qui vont venir mais c'est sûr qu'en
investissant en augmentant l'efficience
de nos opérations sur le bilan de
l'emploi il va avoir un peu moins
d'emplois à la fin c'est clair de
combien environ
on n'a pas encore séché flou ça dépend
sur l'ensemble des projets qu'on
travaille quel va être le plan de match
final c'est sûr que nous on annonce les
projets quand le projet est financé ce
projet d'ailleurs qui est financé à 100%
par rio tinto qu'on vient d'annoncer
aujourd'hui 210 millions de dollars
canadiens on travaille sur d'autres
projets puis on voit des annonces et un
après l'autre quand on va être prêt donc
le bilan net sur l'emploi pas encore me
suffit mais il sera négatif dites vous
en même temps est-ce que dans vos
cartons il peut y avoir une nouvelle
aluminerie qu'ils soient construites
les nouvelles alumineries ce qu'on
regarde ces sujets aurier sur ellis on
veut des carbonisés ont vu des caveaux
10 et d'économie on veut décarboniser
noté industrie donc ça passe
naturellement par elie 6 on regarde des
projets d'hydrogène go si on regarde
beaucoup de projets dans ce sens là donc
une nouvelle aluminerie si une nouvelle
aluminerie fort probablement que ça va
être avec les technologies et lycées
cependant on annonce aujourd'hui l'étude
donc si l'étude est concluant il est
possible qu'on aille au delà des ces
excuses pour la technologie ap60 parfait
on vous suit avec beaucoup d'intérêt
merci beaucoup monsieur avoir été avec
nous ce soir
merci ça fait plaisir bonne soirée pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit